Oh, speaking of LA. Yes. You had quite a tweet.
Jimmy Campbell. Yeah. What's now they're saying they're not going to air it,
which I'm like, just it. Aaron. Aaron has a bomb.
I said to him afterwards, I'm sure it's in your head.
You're your own worst critic. It's pretty good.
If Kim was going back to you being like, we're not airing this.
Yeah. Well it's Jimmy Kim.
I think it's like now tweet the thing is,
is like I tweeted that out and it's like, it's my most, you know,
Twitter lets you know, it's my most favorite ID, retweeted tweet ever.
So they're like, I'm like what? Like this is going to get my,
at least my fans to watch it. Like why not? You know? And uh,
and they're saying they're probably not, but yeah, here's what happened.
So when you do a late night set, David Laderman, Seth Meyers, Jimmy Fallon,
you do it at their studio. Okay. And then you'll do it at the end of the show.
So there have been a whole comedy show, guests and monologues and all that.
And then the producer will come out and say, and the warmup comic would say,
Hey, we got a guy he's going to do five minutes.
Like give them all your attention, give him all your energy, blah, blah, blah.
And then, you know, though Jimmy Kim or whomever, the hostess will say,
you know what? You'll see on TV. The audience will see and you know,
all the way from New York city, please welcome Chris and Stefano.
And then you do the set in the warm, the room is warm. This situation.
It wasn't that it was going to be on Jimmy Kimmel show,
which he does out of Los Angeles.
But the set is filmed from his comedy club in Las Vegas. Uh,
so that's so that's strike one, strike two.
They had a warmup comic due about two and a half minutes. Like not enough time.
And then his sister does comedy.
His sister is a comedian and really nice woman. I just didn't know. You know,
it's, it's a, it's a job to be a professional warmup.
Comic is like a specific job.
Usually the professional warmup comics or as good as standup as they are at
warming up a crowd because it's more than jokes.
You got to play games with them and throw a beach ball around and you know,
tickle people. It's a whole game that you play,
but it works because the crowd's like in a great mood and then they just laugh
at the five minutes of jokes. So I go up, I go up there. The room is,
first of all, you know, the first warmup comic, it was just like, Hey,
like it was 300 people. That's just not conducive. Then the other comic goes up,
student jokes about honor and now or pushing yourself.
I don't know what the jokes are about their jokes about something.
I was kind of listening, not listening. I'm sure she's fine. But I just,
you know, you, you're not really paying attention,
but I do know nobody was laughing. That's what I know.
So I go out there and you can just tell the room. It's like one of those things,
when you walk out to a hot room,
they're clapping and the clapping doesn't stop until you get to like the
microphone or even kick, you have to be like stop at them.
Like I walk out and like I'm not even at the mic and they're just like done,
done. Just like, just my dad's like here for you though.
Or they're here tonight. They're there for a night of comedy.
I don't even think that they know that it's for late night.
I think that they think that they're just going to this comedy club,
they got free tickets. Cause it's a TV taping,
but I don't think they necessarily know.
I don't know how in-depth it was explained. So I go up first.
So I was one of four comics who was going to do their set by the time the fourth
comic one on the crowd was great. I heard that that comic smashed,
but I go up and it's like such a cold room, like,
and I was doing, and the reason why I felt confident, tweeting out,
like I bombed. And it's because I have so much stuff on the internet of my work.
I just on two podcasts before that,
the fighter and the kid and Theo Vaughn's this past weekend podcast,
which combined had already had like over 2 million views downloads. I'm like,
that's the real work in 2020, like the Kimmel shows. Doesn't just,
it doesn't get that many views, not his fault. It's just the,
what it is in America now.
So I already felt like I'm confident I did the work, the,
where I needed to shine. I, I did. Okay. And,
and so I go out there and the first joke that usually gets along of laughs just
kind of bombs. And I was just like, all boy,
I could feel that this is not going to go well,
then the second one gets a full zero, like a full zero.
So I was like, wow, Zs. So then, so then the third one I was telling,
and then in the middle of it, I just stopped. And I was like, you guys suck.
I said that on late night television, I was like, you guys suck.
And then just looked around and then went right back into my junk
and then just continued to gradually get worse and told the last one,
because you have to do a five minute,
another thing you have to do your five minute approved set.
So if that was a normal comedy club, if I, if that wasn't a switch,
I would've just done crowd work, been made fun, went to, you know,
dirtier jokes or jokes that really wake people up. And you can't do that on the,
when you get you that five minutes set is vetted.
So I had to come out and very inorganically. You're like,
you know what America's problem is where like,
I wouldn't say that if I would come out and be like,
what the is wrong with everybody? You know,
like just start yelling about the virus, just start yelling.
And then I would do my set. Right. But I wasn't couldn't do that this time.
So I felt like my hands were tied.
So then the last joke I did was just about getting blow jobs,
which is not TV friendly or approved, but I was like, all right,
at least this is like my clothes that I closed in clubs that this will get a
laugh. And then that,
so even so even with my clothes are that I do in regular
comedy shows just to settle. And I just walked out and um,
and, and the producer and the producer was like, Oh, don't worry.
We'll pump laughs into it. And I said, if you're going to air that thing,
I need you to air it as the bomb. I was like,
cause I'm going to tweet out my experience. She was like, no, no, no,
don't do that. That's not, that's sorry. I was like, the tweets got me.
I was like, I can't wait to get outta here and send this.
And then it was, and then I literally, I mean,
as soon as I got in the car to go to the airport, I,
it opened up Twitter and I just died and I just started throwing it.
And then I got so much support. So many comedians calling me like dying,
laughing, or sending you messages.
But cause there really isn't anything funnier, I think, to a comedian.
Then the two things that make comedians like gut laugh is when a,
a good comedian like really bombs, like what happened,
like really eats it and is trying to get out of it. And they can't,
it's so funny or fart
[inaudible] you can ask, you can ask like the most brilliant comedians,
nothing is funnier than a foreign. It's just like, it's just like a ripping,
a nice fart is like that thing that Barstool posted with a fart hits third year
that I must have, I was crying. My daughter was in a swimming class. Like my,
whereas parents you're supposed to be very vigilant because they're like, Hey,
listen, you know, we're not in the pool, but like as a parent,
keep an eye on your kid. And I literally am like crying,
laughing at that Fort hitting third gear. And my daughter's swimmies fell off.
And she was like, flapping like that. And I'm like, Oh. I was like crying.
And like, you know,
I bet the instructor thought I was crying cause I was nervous,
but I was laughing at the third gear fart.
I feel like part of that though. You have you, uh,
I don't think you ever want to blame the crowd, right? For like, you know,
you're a good comic. It's no, you kill with that material.
And now all of a sudden it's not working.
Maybe you didn't deliver it the same way. Maybe this, maybe that,
but the majority is like that crowd for that night for whatever reason is the
problem.
Yeah. Yeah. I think, I think, listen, it's always,
it's always the comedian's fault at times, but I know that's what.
Say, cause like it's almost like, you know, that's part of the job or whatever,
but you're.
We're in the same jokes that kill every other time. The only thing,
the only reason why I say it was my fault. I yeah,
those jokes deserve there were worked out crafted jokes that have done well in
the past. That's why they got approved to go on the show.
The reason why I'm saying it,
it is still my fault is because all those things that I said, I I'm saying, Oh,
I couldn't do crowd. I could have done it. I actually could have done it.
And then just blown past the line and been like, Hey,
I got them to the place I needed to then do my five minutes.
But because I kind of, you know, in a way, push it out.
I don't want it to push it out.
But like I want it to be like professional on the rules,
basically follow the rules where like, you know,
some more Renegade guys would be like, no, that.
I'm not going to allow myself to go on television. If it's not the crowd I want.
So they would have. So that's why I say like, it kind of is my fault.
It wasn't my fault though is yeah.
Like the way that's set up is just like not conducive to five minute.
Also stand up comedy on a late night show is not really what 2020 is
about. It's not like I can come on here and go on those podcasts.
I mentioned and give you an hour to two hour version of myself.
That'll make somebody say, Oh, I want to buy tickets to go see this person.
As opposed to some shiny business card. Five-minute set where they're like, Hey,
don't say your daughter's Puerto Rican. I'm like,
but she has a tattoo on her attendant. She's four. She is Puerto Rican.
You know what I mean? I'm like, so like why?
Like they're telling you that to be like, Oh,
we don't know if we don't know if we want you to,
we could do this stuff about your daughter, but you know,
just don't even mention her race. I'm like, she's proud.
Her mother is a proud Puerto Rican. Like what are you talking about?
You can't say that your daughter's Puerto Rican, Jimmy Kimmel was okay with it.
But other late night sets have, have said,
have they made the request they make you do?
Like when you see a comedian on late night,
you don't understand like the F they don't want to do that. Now.
That's not the real set.
Like don't judge ever judge a comedian on that because it's like,
they're making, they're putting you in this little box that people know that is
on the podcast. That's why like every time you got to say, come on, I'm like,
yes, because people buy tickets to my after I make appearances here.
Cause they're like, like, Oh, I, I,
at least I get an honest chance to prove myself five minute late. And I said,
you don't get.